mission impossible obviously you pays
your money you want the the big big
stunts our last time you were on the
show you were kind of hinting at this
big set piece in this movie that you'd
spent years preparing yes so I think you
can tell us a bit more about it now
right now I could tell you a bit more
okay
I spent really two years McHugh and I
were talking about a sequence and it's
an aerial sequence with helicopter and
I've wanted I've studied you know many
different films and so when I went and I
got my helicopter license and we're
flying
really yeah I'm sure you see them flying
helicopters before you flying without a
license previously you sort of wonder
you go too quickly I know okay so you
get a license yeah and then we you know
we just started really working on the
sequence to see what can we do practical
I mean I think in terms of action this
is probably the largest practical action
film ever shot like when you look at the
films there's no CGI so we're going
through Paris the motorcycle it's just
full-on cars you know we're all doing
our own stunts and the helicopter
sequence is just incredibly exhilarating
and very dangerous so there's really
only one country that would allow us to
do it where we had to build special
camera rigs and for the helicopter and
so I got my license and we just I
trained up on aerobatic and it's
different I fly aerobatic and airplanes
but helicopters are very different so
we're flying very low very close to rock
faces in a chase and I'm chasing you
know Henry in a sequence we've got some
pictures of it here so now this is -
there you that's you front this is the
end of the sequence for the beginning I
think we've got these pictures the wrong
way around I think no there it's I can't
tell you that right now
okay he's part of all right well well I
just think this might be out of the
wrong victors Henry you're hanging out
of there there's Henry back there flying
he's hanging out he's not even flying a
helicopter
because we're doing aerobatics he's at
least I'd know my own fate no it was
eventually on the on his tail like a
foot off the tail rotor at times he had
no idea that was times right genuinely
thought was like okay this is how it
goes by Tom Cruise lucky because he can
actually fly anyways
[Applause]
here you are right now I'm guessing so
that must be after this next bit because
this next picture you're on the outside
so someone must be flying that
helicopter it can't be
please w so that's that's you I mean
it's it's that is you yeah but this next
picture is one it's just a beautiful
picture but it's crazy so that's you yes
I mean that's because you know Tom does
all this stuff does that mean that you
guys have to say yes where you know
they can't wait you can't get these guys
out of the stunt room do you know what
you can reach like in the helicopter
he's loving it you were freezing that
hello oh we had a kleiner oh yeah we
think this New Zealand winter and the
doors are open you posted a picture you
got a picture on your Instagram of you
doing a stunt which looks very painful
it's B I think it's you being lower down
a cliff by your nipples
[Laughter]
you're you're being lowered off this 18
hundred foot cliff I know I'm perfectly
safe because the stunt crew is
absolutely fantastic
Eastwood team is dentist they're really
good you trust the harness navel
triple-checked everything
but it's still 1,800 foot you're walking
so high and the boats at the bottom in
in the fjord about this big that it
looks like a painting and so you lose
all sense of my fear and adrenaline for
the height
you start thinking if I were to fall can
I kind of like squirrel suit my all the
way to the water maybe just like skim
you two months
obviously you know with child's now so
that makes stunts harder but even when
you did the last movie you seemed quite
unsuited I mean don't you did suffer
from vertigo going into these oh yeah so
I mean a bizarre thing to say yes to
being in one of these films well I
didn't really know what I was saying yes
to okay I don't really know how these
films were made so you know when I was
on the camel in the desert very quickly
and in the first day of shooting Tom
what did we do we jumped off a building
yes the first day of shooting I think
we've got a picture of you so that's me
swearing and shouting the naughtiest
words ever was in my ear even your ear
I'm so sorry swear sir I did I say that
I'm so sorry and then we jump off and he
looks at me and the Tom Cruise kind of
where he goes
welcome to Mission
[Applause]
[Music]
to all of us my schedule day too
you